it all starts
with a dead girl
who is that like whose voice is
that
anonymous narrator did they come back
are they literally just for the
beginning
intro
oh
i want a cup of tea a cup of tea
ever since i was little oh i've had this
dream it's the end of summer
a girl is running through the woods
the moon because she's not the same
voice
as the very beginning
the gunshot
why she made two
it always felt so real she make us a
drink the blood on my cheek the
cold sweat running down my skin
i'd managed to convince myself it really
happened
this scar the memory
part of me i could never fully
understand
[Music]
that was the only part but she doesn't
have a scar on her face so if it is her
then does she
okay that day when the phone rang
it was the hardest day of my life
the day i went home to say goodbye to my
father
to dress him up for his last journey
put him in a suit fix his tie
simple just the things he did every day
this is pretty
[Music]
but it reminds me okay stuff wasn't easy
[Music]
i'm so wet a moment to pull myself
[Music]
together
[Music]
i call the bird poop
i was almost ready falls into place
okay sorry right um
thank you gaming with malachi stream
looks amazing yag
i'm happy got my new pc didn't i
right let's have a look there he is
um can i oh i can read it anyway i was
gonna
try and zoom memorial of the holy
guardian angels
funeral at ten oh i thought someone she
was saying
that she has to dress him up and stuff
for his last journey i was like is he
dead but i thought that might be too
morbid but no this is a horror game
there is nothing too morbid
funeral r10 our lady of the rosary
biopsy oops just kicked it send package
to marianne
marion neurologist visit funeral
1230 ultrasound who is this ultrasound
force
oh it's got to be hers right because she
she keeps having these weird um dreams
so maybe she's having ultrasounds for it
and uh going going to a neurologist
wait why have she got so many bloody
funerals
oh wait does she work in a funeral
that would make more sense let's not
hope that she's had like
three funerals or people she actually
knows in a
in the space of like a week or a month
or whatever that was
that would be horrific is there nothing
else for me to look at in here just that
i guess
just so you know i literally scour
everywhere
i like that book over there butterflies
and moss
[ __ ] what it's a cat nice to see you too
should we follow the cat that's what i
look at come on
wow jack's room
it's like he never
damn it okay
oh right this is his place jack
was part of the solidarity movement
he spent a few months in an internment
camp but even that couldn't dampen his
spirit and he was a religious man
come on jack where'd you put it okay
let's do this the other way
the hell is this
all right because we're gonna dress them
up so we need all of this stuff to
looking
fancy i didn't even know that that was
something
i think that's it what no i haven't
finished
upstairs i don't care time to say
goodbye
okay i used to think i'd never fit in
but jack he didn't mind my weirdness
i'm so weak he's special
i'm so weird no one gets me
you know i'm always the outcast
keep hissing at me who do you think's
gonna feed you now
meow jack was a humble
religious man he ran a funeral home
and i'd help out there you go it felt
good to be useful
jack ran the funeral home okay
okay let's go out here she had very
scary eyes for a second there
what's around here then
we lived upstairs from jack's funeral
home
it wasn't as weird as it sounds
besides if it wasn't for that i may
never have learned to use my powers
oh her parallel world jumping powers
interesting don't you eat oh
it was a wacky
reference if so very impressed oh
let's feed the cat i don't want to put
the funeral
can we feed the guy yes let's feed the
guy
and to think we could have left without
feeding the cat
here you go what's your face
glad to see you're still kicking around
do you want some water
i just got an achievement for that cutie
let's have a look at this
miners from the sears of mine came to
work today as usual but instead of
flashlights and pickaxes they
carried a black casket adorned with lit
candles a symbol of their company's
demise
this is not the death of our mind say
members of the sierras and mine
rescue committee we will not let our
jobs be buried this casket is meant for
the
vistula coal company the miners have
also announced that they will come to
work tomorrow
they refuse to accept that the sierras
the mine was
liquidated meanwhile their colleagues
continue to protest outside the company
headquarters in taiki building a
symbolic wall
in the entrance each day they add
another layer of bricks
there are only five left until the wall
reaches the ceiling
nato's new mission why do i need to know
this
earlier today u.s president bill clinton
delivered a major foreign policy address
to commemorate the fall of the berlin
wall
okay cool cool cool love to know all
information
i can't believe it's all still here he's
a photographer
nice jack
illuminate photo for five seconds dip in
there
multigrade for three seconds dip and
stop for three seconds and
fix it i did this once in my life
can can we get a picture and then do the
thing
oh damn it we have to find a picture
first
unless there's gonna be a picture
already in there for us probably not
though
i guess i forgot about this one oh here
we go
i can do it now i was wrong
um illuminate photo for five seconds
this is how i eliminate it
one two three four
five
illuminated photo i'm guessing we just
go this way right
so this is uh three seconds three
seconds three seconds
one two three
yes
one two three
oh get a bit freaky now one
two three what was the last photo i took
of you jack
can you do that wrong like if i left it
in for two more seconds would have gone
wrong
probably not
okay so i know there's something that
way but i don't think i've
haven't gotten down here can i get oh
something here
uh i'm guessing that's the way out don't
you
i don't want to go yeah wait hold up
we'll explore can i run i guess i
shouldn't really
run through our dead dad's home
this is the way
i out it might be you know because it's
the outside isn't it
hey nelson i'm doing good thank you no
i can't go back i miss the room [ __ ]
whatever don't do that guys don't do i
just did the door closes me you can't go
back
ghosts
very nice cinematic shots
i guess they're they're trying to do an
uh
a mix of like fixed camera angles aren't
they
which i can admire i was thinking about
this the other day actually
how it would be done nowadays
jack taught me to accept my
condition of all my foster parents
oh he was the only one who saw it as a
gift
and not a curse uh
my controller is vibrating i don't know
why
hidden boss battle now i've probably got
to just be the rain
it's dripping on my controller
oh hello oh
fitting
oh can i peek through here oh i've got
the home
key
so i could have a little peek
jack's in the prep room
then can you guys hear okay
i think you are you caught me out if not
where should we go
what room is this that's the prep room
let's look around a bit for us
[Music]
male 1 that's
her dad adam newark
car accident
there they are
is it
here it is ah i didn't even know that i
couldn't get into the room yet i just
had chosen not to go
fair enough
[Music]
takes a special type of person to be
able to work
in a funeral home i couldn't do it i
definitely couldn't do it be so sad
are all these doors locked when they're
expecting her
i guess you gotta be safe
thanks for subscribing alex
oh
not sure if i'm ready for this
gotta be i know that's him i'm just
having a little look
what a cool jacket we can put that one
on
what's this
okay
i guess there's only one thing we can do
here
hey jack oh
when she was like jack's waiting for me
downstairs this is what she meant
why not i got your special clip
now where's your tie i don't know
should i not put him back in fair enough
look for your tie where is the tie
i hope it wasn't in that room that i
forgot to go in
scheisse
if it actually was then i oh there it is
never mind
where did that come from was that there
before
i don't think i could have picked it up
before combine
tie with tie clip oh my god
tedious snazzy you wouldn't have it any
other way
i didn't expect this to be easy
i guess i didn't know what to expect
when things get personal it
just burns you from the inside out
there i guess you're ready
hmm
oh can't you people read
the sign says closed
sorry i'll stop that
it's pretty cool
oh [ __ ] now
it's creepy let's go
shadow man
[Music]
what the hell
[Music]
kitty guess you felt it too
and then it happened as it did so many
times before
just when i thought my day couldn't get
any worse
oh
where is that darn notebook
i'm going to be late i need to find that
marianne oh
marry him oh she's in like the world of
the dead are you crying my child
why is his face like that
it's fine jack yeah now
you didn't happen to see my notebook
it's so cool
side by side my memory's a bit fuzzy
so much for aging gracefully
listen jack
you should probably get some rest forget
the notebook
oh no no i've got so much work my dear
it's okay
no i i can't just let it go
it's not important
you are crying what's wrong with you
maybe something bad happens if they
realize he died
it's
what would i okay do without you
jack don't worry about it
it's time to get some rest
i'm worried about the surgery
when i'm at the hospital are you sure
you're going to be all right
jack it's gonna be fine
oh you know i promised myself once
i would never let anything happen to you
not while i'm around
i'll be fine i promise
no risky stuff man right
all right jack
yeah get some rest i need yes
yeah she's taking them out of like limbo
or whatever goodness
i love you my child oh i've loved you
since the moment you walked into my life
remember that
always
well she's got to say goodbye that's
quite nice
most people would give anything to have
that opportunity
to say all the things that were left
unsaid
but it didn't make things any easier i
could help
a thousand souls cross over but when it
came to jack
it still hurt like hell i love you too
daddy
yeah so it's like limbo
i used to think everyone saw the world
the way it's like glowing flawed
divided torn between two realities
but no
i was the only one
or so i thought
we're closed there's another funeral
home across town
i can give you the number marianne
who is this you don't know me marianne
but i know you look if this is a joke
you need to listen to me marianne okay
i'm hanging up i know what you are
what who is this my name
is thomas i need your help
listen if that's all you've got to
shadow
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
hello
[ __ ]
[Music]
it's not dark yet what so like
some darkness is taking over like
silent hill
a bluebird team production oh here we go
is very fun hill
how they would have those little uh
videos at the beginning
really creepiest ones especially the
[Music]
room
[Music]
[Music]
oh
[Music]
experimenting on kids maybe
with pigeons
[Music]
sweet
very silent hill the music take
thanks for following riza reza
and off i went on nothing but a hunch
a call from a complete stranger
but i'd learned to trust my instincts
and there was something about this guy
his voice felt like i should know him
either way you sure seem to know me
[Music]
maybe maybe he was the
ominous narrator voice in the very
beginning
the neva workers resort right off the
bat
i could feel there was something off
about that place
anyone home i guess not definitely not
cool don't know i want that maybe a nice
little collectible for me
what the hello
zombies
there be zombies
where my glasses i can't see
without my glasses
so look at this knob
what the hell
does this man live where are we going
warning do not enter the front gate was
locked up tight
i needed to find another way in
thanks for following race dragon
you want to keep me up neva
okay let's go find this man's glasses
they're gonna have to do better than
that
not a whole lot of people knew about
neva
it used to be a government-owned
vacation resort
until one day it just stopped
and so an urban legend was born
the neva massacre the details were
always fuzzy
crazed workers ancient curses
you know the usual
where did that might go
hmm
no ball
oh my god of course there's got to be
kids in the game if it's going to be
anything like silent hill
maybe it's just from the massacre
hello oh
there is something here in the parallel
world of the undead
and by something i mean a child
the horror the horror
that's weird
so
huh all right what's this
tnk
1968. who could that be
i wonder
is it a little better hang print on the
tnk
hey blonde crow welcome to the stream
he says you're new here
got the bloody run
the camera just kind of guides me anyway
so i don't really know why there's this
mechanic of like
following footprints might be my way
i mean i get it but the camera is
literally telling me where to go
ronnie the unearth remains
renovation works has been suspended
i'm sure we'll be fine something
happened here
they love doing this in games a little
tight
claustrophobic uh camera angles
and they go wide
[Music]
the split would come and go if a place
had a story to tell well
i guess i was there to listen hello
hello
this is cool
okay why should we try first
i guess the only way we can go can we go
up here
a and x which one's a
this one
huh
dead
like everything else in this place but
not in the undead
that's weird it's dead in the real place
but undead
no undead not dead yeah undead
the other place but we can't do anything
with it
oh great there's that bloody kid this
bloody ball
he's in love though that's cute
in love with the ball
i'm here hearing
like a creature growling
and stifle screams sometimes it's pretty
cool
i should really just immerse myself in
this the place
felt old and soaked in misery
figures i guess a thousand years of
history doesn't just happen
it's paid for but even in the deepest
darkness light can linger
lonely fragile
waiting for someone oh that's really
freaking cool
look i was looking in the left side
then i looked on the right side and i
realized that's really cool
as i absorbed the energy i wondered who
it was that
left it behind a dying soldier
whispering the name of his beloved
or maybe just glad to be done with this
world i think it was a
i think it was a boy a boy and his ball
and the love for his ball whispering
his final words about his multicolored
ball
okay so now i have this energy when i
use it
uh to power up this guy
thanks for hosting wraith dragon in any
case
i figured i could use it energy's energy
right
[Music]
oh geez so that worked it did work
good for you marianne these powers
of mine as much of a pain in the ass as
they were
they did come in handy sometimes
okay so we
can't decide when to use it it just kind
of happens whenever we get a headache
there i was existing in two worlds
but never really living in either
what are those particles
oh they're leaves
what season is it
it must be winter it's not quite autumn
is it
oh this is a nice shot very cinematic um
what the what the hell are you neva
the aura and that the eye of sarah seen
others like it
but never this intense
it was like a landfill of memories
emotions
and none of them good
can we use it what
okay that was weird
yay we can't use the telephone
hello to find the echo
oh this thing i'm here
no there's definitely something trust me
you made the right call sending me yes
it's only a matter of time
even the objects here had auras
when i touched them i could sense their
stories
words images feelings
left behind
still arrows pointing this way
but i feel like i need to go up those
steps ah too many decisions i'm sure the
game will tell me what to do
right summer of 1969
inauguration the first secretary of the
polish united workers party comrade
honored krakow and took part in an
official
inauguration of the neoad resorts the
new center of the socialist joy and
recreation
working class of lesser prolonged
finally has a place to spend family time
in the
in the bosom of nature and nature's
bosom
the main building and the lodge area a
comfortable yet simple
as simple are the socialist
socialistic spirit of philosophy special
thanks to the architect future manager
this was like a place for normal people
to come
and chill hang out together all that
kind of stuff
i don't think we'll be allowed in here
and then we'll have to go follow the
arrows
i'm such a good predictor hello
anybody in there
locked obviously there's got to be
another way
well she was looking over here for a
second
ah oh [ __ ]
the handle's missing maybe i could
replace it with something
okay oh no
dead creepy
what is that something up there ah
i think there's a broken window up there
if only i could reach it hmm
[Music]
creepy creepy kids
if you call us something was watching
like a shadow was watching through
one of the windows it says to go up this
way too there's loads of arrows going
everywhere i don't think this leads
anywhere though
that's hopscotch
i said something
okay what am i supposed to do
it's that one right
don't quite know
that's weird she's like i sent something
okay
what do you want me to do about that
pop that scotch maybe i can't can i do
it
one two three oh i messed up
i mean i can see the kids been all over
it
creepy ass kid
this music is nice
just enough suspense
now what's a fine machine like you doing
in a place like this
doubling as a spare bedroom apparently
oh the video flashbacks were from this
place in the beginning hope you don't
mind if i uh
pop your trunk who's been sleeping here
[Music]
not much here what
trunk opens this way
although this could come in handy
great jesus bloody christ
what the hell tonight someone's angry
ass
no one here
that did give me a bit of a jump
anything else down this way
i don't think
oh
oh i can't go that way i thought i was
onto something then
what's this broad horizons
handheld mobile phones the future of
communication
global eradication of smallpox the
greatest medical achievement of our time
and there's a new soviet spacecraft soon
to depart we need to stop doing that now
we need to stop um sending things into
space
we got too much rubbish
is already around the earth
if aliens actually ever did visit earth
they'd just see it as one massive trash
can
let's go i'm done looking around
so i'm guessing we can use that
screwdriver
don't know why we surveyed the broken
window though i mean we can't get up
there but
i think we can use the screwdriver again
perfect size so began the great dumpster
heist of 1999.
said a mannequin of course it's a
mannequin
we are actually looking at oh we're
dragging our dumpster right okay gotcha
could he be creepy
that's just the only one that i can
interact with
i'm starting to get tired of your [ __ ]
neva
you better be worth it
ah
yeah carefully broken glass
uh
oh
what's that i uh
okay so it's true
the neva mask i need to find this thomas
guy and get the hell out of here
seems like it is true
i can still hear screams can you guys
hear it can you hear the screams like
the ambient noises
if not i'm turning out the game
anyone thomas
you there because i'm not being alone in
this
hearing them creepy sounds travis style
travel with camford travel with
what does that say powder milk
it doesn't say that
spring
10 sewing techniques for fashionable
skirts
love that okay
ah the polish
legends of the dragon of wow hill i love
that you know apparently there's dragons
that are supposed to be
around like where i live right now and i
find it extremely exciting
i i read a story about a dragon
that was in a pool of water uh
about an hour's drive from where i live
and there was like an um
a story written about it in the
newspapers
this was like a long time ago turns out
what it actually was the pool of water
was literally just like
a pond a very deep pond i'll give it
that but it was
tiny and i was so disappointed but
anyway that's where i was supposed to
live
fun fact
but the bones of a
um
thought to be extinct like dinosaur
type reptilian were found around where
the
the dragon sightings were so they're
thinking that actually maybe that was
what it was it was just like a
prehistoric
esque lizard type of creature that
wasn't really anywhere else
and people just thought it was a dragon
where is my kissling
okay do i need to know these names boris
boris
vote for pedro wait
is that a um is that a napoleon dynamite
that i am thinking about the right thing
right is that a reference
a what's the bedrock as soon as we
damned
is that depressed
stay in the lines i am cat and i
licking my balls so what the hell
lying here waiting for you
but that's just silly hahaha i feel so
pathetic and
ugly oh swag
uh okay interesting
okay this game really wants me to go
towards here
hello
thomas
easy marianne it's just a good
old-fashioned
haunted hotel calm your ass down and
answer the bell what about
on the on the bike
oh god i haven't even checked out these
awesome sofas yet let me check out the
orphan sofas
got another postcard what an idea
i haven't been turning them around my
dearest i know i promise to visit but
guess what
i got promoted yes really meet the new
chief of staff
i really think this might be it a fresh
start a place to call
home for us i mean you me and the kids
i know it sounds crazy but just think
about it
yours forever f
so what's this then my love summer oh
they're all from
f some are in full swing the resort is
stuffed to the gills
and you know what that means more work
for yours truly but it's good work
honest work
mr wrecker wicks said he'd like to keep
me on can you believe it
i won't screw this up not this time i
promise
and what about this one
news says hello you won't love it here
no you
would love it here my dear amazing day
room for the kids and free art lessons
lots of families and the hotel is huge
i've never seen anything like it
wish you were here with me miss you okay
so there we go
oh it's the groundskeeper cute
okay we've got to go answer that bell
they're probably getting very pissed off
that we're just like reading all of our
postcards
here i'm just ignoring about but i want
to look at this
i like that art okay okay we're coming
jesus this way
this way
oh was that like here it is
um
you startled me i did didn't i
you look real scared
i'm sadness what marianne
sadness is that your name
i mean you seem pretty cheerful to me
well it's what i remember my friends
used to call me by a different name
but i don't remember what it was
your friends oh yeah i used to have
a lot of friends here
but they're all gone now
why do they all have those masks of
their faces
i don't really want to talk about it
that that's okay
so do you live here
she's gone all by yourself
oh you wouldn't believe how boring it
gets sometimes
i can imagine
this place must have been
[Music]
to play with must have been nice
it was hmm not anymore
so
tell me what happened
i remember people stopped coming
only a few of them stayed
but they became very sad
very angry they might hurt you
thanks that i can take care of myself
hey i was wondering have you seen
marianne yes
would you play with me just
no it's been so long since i played with
anything oh okay
okay can we help her crossovers
yes that's bad to see over here
anything i understand
the second floor we can look there come
on
hurry wait i can't go that way
damn i need to get up there somehow
well at least she's not creepy that's a
good thing
[Music]
gamer with malik i said long did she
really try to shake the wrong hand of
the girl with one arm that makes sense
because i didn't know if she kind of put
her hand up
and then put it back down again maybe i
didn't i didn't notice that
but you might be right there
okay and then she realized an elevator
that's happening if it works it's not
gonna work come on
the people's food
the day room
oh what the hell it works
how uh
did she say just she just said upstairs
she just remembers sad [ __ ]
oh okay marianne just take a deep breath
and
an out-of-body experience
let go
oh so now i'm following this in this
world
okay
there a fuse box needs some energy to
spark it up
this is free to move fast why
[Music]
can't i go up there gotta go fast
hurry up an out of body experience
it's like taking a plunge into
nothingness
stay under for too long and it just
pulls you eats me where the [ __ ] can i
get this
energy source from then because i'm
turning into nothing here
[ __ ] i feel like uh i feel like i'm
gonna die
[Music]
friends forever let's go where the [ __ ]
do i get this energy so oh my god we
gotta go
oh okay gotcha
thank god i thought i had to run all the
way back
okay so should we try again then
no i can't do it yeah i gotta go out
body experience thing
okay oh there it is it's right there
so we went completely the wrong way last
time but that's fine that's okay
we deal with it
this should be something over here see
it sounds like a siren
you guys hear that
okay marianne now get your ghostly ass
back and
power up that elevator
quick oh god i'm not gonna make it
am i still charged up i think
yeah lucky me
[Music]
uh
there we go
[Music]
[Music]
cool
the art of the internationally acclaimed
paint for the first time
oh can't go up there no i can't go with
that
whoa
what am i supposed to do then just go
off another one
i guess
it doesn't seem like there's much house
i can do here
[Music]
okay now where did she go
where did you come from where did to go
no i don't think that song
jesus
stop these spooky games spooky vibes
don't ruin it
i don't think you can go into any of
these routes
boy that kind of
sucks
okay where are you gonna let me go then
hmm
don't say nowhere
second floor
it's really nowhere that i can go on
this floor
okay i guess
i don't know where to go then
back on four one
okay so i can't go up these steps but
that's fine because we'll just go up to
floor three anyways
can i you can i pick up this poster and
just use it as like a little
uh a little bridge no
why not
i'm actually stuck
not too sure where i'm supposed to go
of course there was that um
[Music]
there's that fence down there but i
couldn't go past that anyway
so i can't go up there as her either
maybe there's more places i can go on
the other side
nice to see a polish game on stream
honestly
i i do have a lot of respect for blooper
team
i think what they do is great uh
with the horror genre
i really enjoyed uh blair witch
jesus but i'm what am i supposed to
bloody do here
that's so strange
maybe i have a look as
her around here
oh there's a window open there can i get
to that window
can i look in this broken glass
hmm
aha what do we have here
well the camera cuts down here so maybe
if we go down here
a hidden hallway why was it so hard to
find
what is
seriously what the hell why did it take
me so long to find this bloody hallway
okay not getting through here
[Music]
that door is so shiny then
i'm i'm like
i have a spirit shield whoa
dude holy [ __ ]
i didn't even know i could do that
whenever stuff happens i'm like darting
from one side of the screen to the other
like
where is the threat i mean it's probably
in the ghosty side but
[Music]
okay
[Music]
we know where we can use this
i went back as hair so i have more time
wait but let's just check the hallway
first because
why the hell not well but maybe it
carries on the game okay we'll go back
i'm so infuriating i'm so sorry
wait are the bugs back here
i have my special shield
okay so i can't go back anymore
there's a hole in there
i like this just being able to
i don't know survey areas that you've
been
and you're perhaps going to just
makes you feel a little bit more in
control
i've always liked peepholes and games i
don't know why
maybe it's just uh feeds my furious
voyeuristic curiosities
for your stick
there's so much to look at having like
two sides of the screen to uh okay i
should go to the end of that hallway
because i
feel like this is where we're supposed
to go
yes i'm working on it
yes i know i just yes
i understand just give me some time
a few days you'll get what you want
oh that voice do you know it
i don't know why but it gives me shivers
good or bad we're pretty bad
looks like the only way great no
we have not explored everything yet
we will be back
let's just go and have a look
oh how do we get out this way
don't like the sound of those creepy
crawlies
oh my god that is so sand hill what the
hell look at that
brings me right back to that gross
it looks like flesh yeah is that
skin if you have a knife
you can just right down there
and then you can just uh shimmy shimmy
i guess they're allowed to do that
because it's not they're not like pro
you can't rip off you know sun hill
can't just be like
we use skin skins
curtains no one else can use skin
curtains now
so uh yeah
a skin soft barrier baby
this room it feels
cold memories of
grief sadness loneliness
is that a cradle
ah the spark's too weak to absorb
it's like it's missing something
some objects soak up moments from the
past
just squeeze in the right spot and let
it pour out
okay
use out to find the point of
recollection
ah sunflower weary of time
for my favorite nurse oh mr tarkovsky
you shouldn't have please
it's the least i can do for all the good
work you do around here
an actual happy memory so there's more
to this place
mr tarkovsky
what a ladies man
ah sunflower weary of time
wow he is uh
he's quite tall an
old prescription i know these drugs
all too well electric shock
depression hysteria insomnia and
malnutrition
treated with electroshock therapy no
or is that supposed to be some new type
of medicine
electroshock refill six times
let's do now [ __ ] there are thousands of
them
i'm gonna need more energy to get
through goodbye
can i walk down home
i hear whispers
these are the pills the medication
idiot
useless old hag why would he care any
more than the others
it's more than grief more than despair
this letter crushed her spirit oh we
haven't read it yet
dear ursula you're probably wondering
why
i would write this letter instead of
expressing myself directly
the reason i'm afraid is painfully
simple i'm writing this because i'm a
coward
because i couldn't bring myself to look
you in the eye and say what is meant to
be said
what must be said because the mere
thought of breaking the heart of someone
so
oh my jesus that moves really fast um
someone so delicate so fragile is simply
more than i can bear
ursula my dearest ursula these past few
months have brought joy to my heart
to know you're there for me to feel our
friendship blossom
and yet that is all it can be friendship
close pure true but never more
please try to understand being this
close this
exposed to someone has never been easy
for me
life and its struggles have left me
changed
damaged in ways you couldn't possibly
comprehend
you deserve someone to hold you to share
life's joys
and sorrows with you how i wish i could
be that person
but i'm not words cannot express my
regret
as i know deep in my heart this marks
the end of our friendship
please forgive me forever your friend
our team
isn't that the um the doctor
told talkowski
he's bad man i've got a feeling about it
okay can i get back
this is sadness that's literally what
she's called a sad nursey
oh that's gonna be her the one um
who got the letter sadnessy
and maybe we'll meet this nurse
okay so there's something missing wait
did we pick anything up
could we not put in the um
the pills can you pick them up or
something
huh weird
uh-huh
[Music]
on the wall it says come at me i'm in
for another dive
if only i had something sharp
what's that i can see something on the
other screen
okay let's go
oh god i hate this
oh it's another one of these guys but
wait
yes
hello sexy bath time oh
moving
i wasn't expecting me it hasn't been
very scary yet
i just gave myself a headache
no sexy bath time
yes yes yes
shame regret
all right so how do i do this thing
i think i need to get my other part of
me over there first i go anywhere else
while i'm here
i think i just need to get the other
part of me over there okay
all right nice
let's try this out then oh we get to do
it myself
lovely job
quite like that they let you do it
yourself you have to cut down
yeah that was disturbingly satisfying
agreed
oh yeah see we're back here again
what's here
taps toothpaste
what am i looking at
all right
you
i know you're there
i wish i had the strength to cut you
out you don't deserve to exist
you're nothing
there have been times when i thought
about ending it
all but i was too afraid that a part of
me would go on
trapped on the other side forever
i can imagine that that would be awful
actually
being in her position and knowing like
what's what awaits you after death
that's weird audio just stopped
um
the light of a memory is strong enough
to defy this place
spooky oh an artist was here
oh wait it says hell hell
you are that's me
let's do this
you want me to read you another one
darling
oh look at this mess
don't worry i'll clean you up in no time
i'm here for you my love
this man tarkovsky
he ended up as her patient
huh maybe she did something to him when
he said that he could maybe he's not the
evil one
so
we're still not charged up enough yet
though are we
no i don't think so
can i gain charge from them
see i can't go out there in the normal
[Music]
world
maybe now we can do this
the spark's too weak to absorb it's like
it's
missing something i don't understand
aha there
now it's strong
there we go now we can go
make our little shield
like
medium rare
well i guess we go up then
one sec let me have a look
nope ain't no growing up that way unless
i can go up as hard
oh really game you're gonna do that to
me
that was just cruel guys that was just
cruel
if you're not gonna let her go up there
at least just put something on this oh
that was cruel
that was mean okay
ugh
oh we're back here and now we have our
trusty knife
yeah you know what these skin sheets
remind me of
apart sun hill obviously but also doctor
who
you know like one of the really old
doctor who's where the last
human on earth was like a rag of skin
how was that a kiss thing so freaking
scary
i have note
what am i gonna do
can i just run through there
can i go back to the same energy source
can i go back to the same energy source
huh that's a very good question i will
be able to go back that way
[ __ ]
hmm why could i do
oh the energy sauce down there
so we could just go back around again
a bit of backtracking
never hurt anyone
there we go
but what we have to use it to get past
the bugs again [ __ ] sake
unless i try not to use it all
maybe there's a way not to use it all
[ __ ]
uh i'm pretty sure i've done all the
skin doors nikki
maybe i have enough left now
okay [ __ ] this we're going
hopefully hopefully we can make it
oh we made it
oh wow what a room
reclaiming history fire erupts in the
sky
explosions echo across the wilderness
sparks rain down on the ruins of fort
polus pulaski a once
impenetrable fortress that saw some of
the most intense fighting during
the 1945 offensive against hitler's
forces
this time however it was not the bombs
or mortar fire that lit up the night sky
but a spectacular display of fireworks
that marked the grand opening of
the niwa workers resort
this event was attended by the leaders
of the party
including the first secretary who had
this
to say during the gala let this site a
victoria's struggle
against the forces of evil become a
place of respite for the working people
of the republic
in times of peace and prosperity
liberated in january 1945 by the
heroic red army the historical landmark
is currently
undergoing renovations and will soon be
open to the public at large
the new world workers resort will
welcome its first guest by the end of
june
and it was a disaster
such a weird room
it's just like extra dirty and bad
it's almost complete the main building
turned out better than expected
now it's just a matter of finishing up
the less obvious parts of the resort
god damn this place is perfect remote
peaceful
hidden away from prying eyes talk about
hiding in plain sight
it took some doing to convince him to
let him stay
luckily i can be quite persuasive when i
need to
oh yeah i think i finally got it i'll
call it niwa
apparently this is the troubled man's
notes
why is he troubled i wonder
there's something else here old invoices
outdated documents wonder why someone
put them out here
and we can't read
what the heck is that
is that the little girl yeah she's got
one arm
what is she doing like shooting peas
at this man carrying groceries
with white hair
yeah that's definitely what she's doing
shooting peas
all right bye def thanks for coming
it's just called old man old man doesn't
like it when i should pees at him
i don't know why
oh he's a manager marianne oh jesus
christ
sadness we gotta stop meeting like this
i told you to follow me
take it easy sad this place is huge
it's easy to get lost just just stick
with me okay
i'll stick like a tick
[Music]
you're funny this
thomas rekovich
listen hon you said you remembered
someone named thomas oh and she said to
come upstairs
was it thomas rekovich was he the
manager here
i i guess you think he stuck around
i'm not sure
there was an old man here
very recently i think
and you think it was the old man that
you shot peas at
i don't know old man all look the same
all wrinkly
hey that's not very nice
if he's still around i've got an
infestation to report
marianne uh i feel oh
i don't think we should be here it's
okay sadness
look there's no one here
sadness maybe you should listen to
sadness i mean
we did just get jump scared through a
bloody
peephole into a bathroom earlier it all
hit me as soon as i entered the room
anguish fear
longing
that super freaking cool just left shot
i i like this what the hell
happened here
it still works someone's been using it
wait you can combine it with the razor
blade
too small to fit a door but a cabinet
a drawer someone jotted this down
recently
the troubled man get up
don't turn off that alarm clock
medication double check the forest path
get to the hotel clear out the old
newspapers
get on with the research develop photos
if there's time
oh we might be able to develop some more
photos that'd be fun
double check the office books check up
on
owl
do we know who al is
is that the nurse
burn marks broken glass and
is that salt too many tequilas
[Music]
my senses jolted as i touched the phone
i could tell it had been used recently
to call me
oh [ __ ] this was thomas
and he knows us somehow how does he know
this
okay sure he can't be
a bad person like
can he you wanted help he wanted our
help
and opening i assume hey is that the
first
secretary they must have had some big
plans for this place
which one do you reckon uh thomas is
shelley was an old man with white hair
so i'm guessing it's this one
this one here
i could instantly tell there was more to
that clock than met the eye
all right there is some things like she
doesn't need to give us
every bit of help but this game is very
it helps me a lot but maybe that's just
because i'm still relatively at the
beginning so
there we go
that's as far as it goes
there an imprint
is that thomas
i guess let's go find out as i moved the
clock hand i realized it was a junction
between realities it's rare
but i've seen it before
[Music]
no don't do it
i can't we
must
we must watch that gave me no
new information
that's a lot of rooms was i say water
pumps door
big door the door
for needed the door is needed
change the place to
day room maybe glass wall
so in the way of like revamping this or
something
maybe second room
oh this is cool this is pretty cool
the room isn't as messed up now
wait i can feel
something's wrong it's coming
it's coming why is a little girl scared
of him too
maybe she's not scared of him
looks like a passage okay hold up one
sec
[ __ ] i thought i had it this time
it's taking too long what am i missing
i don't know
looks like i'm in for another dive
[Music]
someone tried real hard to keep this
place a secret
wonder what's in here on the other side
looks like a little smiley face on the
floor
there's not much around here there's a
fuse box but he's charged that one
okay oh what are you
catching me oh yeah i can't go beyond
that
so i have a little bit of i thought i
had some energy left
it's so cool how you slowly just start
to like
turn into nothing okay
we're going to try that because i heard
him not find anything
hmm guys
anyone know any any ideas any smart
ideas
it really looks like i could go through
there but i guess
i guess not
[Music]
hmm
hmm
well i'm probably gonna start wrapping
up
this soon anyway but i want to
try and figure out this
[Music]
i wonder if there's any other way
oh no okay that's oddly
did the ghost girl lock the door behind
us that's not
nice maybe there's
another place in the clock
it's gonna give me
did we see him like this
gotta check the wiring i hate to get
stuck in there
maybe this changes as i keep reversing
time
[Music]
okay let's keep doing it
a spirit well i could absorb some of
that energy
perfect that's just what i wanted
let's have a look at him first
i'm so lost without you i don't know if
i can do this
enough get it together
who's he talking about
perfect now let's open that secret
entrance again
and regret
it is really cool
let's see if it worked
did it just unlock the door
what did it do then wait am i stupid
i must have done something here
[Music]
i must have done something
[Music]
maybe back to the clock
i don't know why that would do anything
now
oh it's so cool it's just so cool how it
changes
can i go outside
i really don't know what that zap of
electricity is done
any ideas anyone
hmm
what is it done
it went through the walls
went through the walls
maybe it's just something in still in
that realm
not in my one
perhaps
yeah i've done whatever i needed to do
hey nicole and abigail sorry i
i'm not intelligent enough to know
spanish
bonita maybe no
[Music]
weird
well if i can't figure this out now
i might as well just call it a night
hey bruno
i'm just so confused it went over the
wall
so i thought well at first i thought
okay it's obviously the door
and then i thought okay let's change
something in
here so this door is gonna open
like something magic
wait
unless this is a secret button
no i thought i just found something
secret oh
i thought there was like a secret desk
button
and then it would uh move
that along
no secret desk buttons
no secret disc buttons
darn it
no special book that i can pull out
i love how it literally like 10 minutes
ago it's like this game it's so
handholdy and now i'm like
i don't know why that what to do
wait what's this signature
so he designed this whole place who are
you
who are you
and is he scary or not is what i want to
know
because the little girl seems scared but
i don't know if she was actually scared
or
like of him or perhaps it was uh
that she was gonna go in there and find
something and
something else wasn't gonna be happy
about it
yeah i already i'm not too sure what to
do
uh josie said maybe you should go back
the building might have changed
all right i don't know what you mean
i've gone back and forth in time
and i've gone back and forth
hmm
all looks pretty standard to me
the room doesn't change the two times
that opens and closes or not that i saw
anyway when i went in there because i
went in there both times
it was just about getting the uh
electricity into that fuse box
and then a buzz like a zap of
electricity went to the left
so leading you back to the way that you
came
but then i got lost and i don't know
what i'm supposed to do
i got an achievement for spirit walking
oh
that's the second time it opened
oh what am i supposed to do
i don't know i don't know
well i think that's it let's call it a
night
we'll try and figure out what to do next
week
anyway thanks so much for watching
uh thank god it's not like the old sand
hill games where you had to find
uh the save points as well that's very
nice
they don't really ever do that in games
nowadays
so it makes it very easy to just stop
whenever you like
and then start whenever you like very
good
um but no so far i think it's
uh very unique i
like its take i mean they haven't shied
away
from being a game that wants to resemble
silent hill and ways
and is obviously heavily inspired by son
hill
um
it's a as a fan of sun hill
it's like enjoyable i wouldn't say
it was a sun hill game um
it seems well i don't know because i
feel like i'm still like at the very
beginning of it it's
very um it's like a narrative mystery
going on right now and the narrative is
a heavier focus than
the horror elements of the game but to
be fair
sound hill was never like a in your face
jump scare horror games so
uh i'm totally cool with that and i i
like games with a nice
heavy narrative especially with a lot of
bits and pieces here and there that
aren't
necessarily thrown in your face and you
can kind of
piece piece the narrative
puzzle pieces together i enjoy that so
i think i'm going to enjoy this game and
i've already screamed once
so you know it can't be that um
not scary so uh yeah
i like it
[Music]
yeah and the um the dual perspective is
really cool
i i love the idea of because obviously
sun here was always you would explore
an area and then the sirens would go and
then you have to re-explore it again and
you'd notice maybe
hidden rooms or or stuff like that that
you hadn't even noticed were there
in the original
walkthrough of the place uh which is
really really cool so you
you were kind of backtracking but you
felt like you were in a whole new
environment which
granted it's a really really clever way
of getting around all of the limitations
that they had back then
um it was very very clever um
but anyway i'm enjoying this i like this
i did see a comment
um saying that they wished you could
kind of
see splits of everything and it seems
like that's
the way the game is going now but i
understand why they wouldn't want to do
that perhaps in more open worldy
scenarios because that's
a lot for the game to render and handle
it's like basically
two split versions of the same scene
um that's a lot but i'm
very impressed with it right now i think
you guys are enjoying it as well from
what i can see in the comments which is
good
ah thanks everyone for watching i'm
gonna be back at the same time
next week perhaps even a little bit
earlier because i was a little bit late
today because
it's my first stream on my new pc and
i'm so happy that all you guys are
saying that it looks so much better
uh very very good very good and i'm
getting to play this game on like the
highest
highest graphical quality so
very exciting times it's the first time
i've ever been able to do that
so i'm very happy